and and I'll probably get myself in
trouble again but what I felt bad about
and I wanted to give him a platform is I
said and now having watched the show a
little bit of VB you know I did feel bad
for the amount of attacks that Tom was
getting whether he [__] up or not I
felt bad he's a human being and he was
being attacked and maybe he deserves to
be attacked that's not the point I felt
bad for Ariana because whatever happened
to her and it's horrible not only
happened to her but happened publicly
and everything that happens to you guys
happen and I felt bad for Rael who
probably did a stupid thing and young
and she's ended up in a in a mental
health uh facility and I'm just going oh
my God these
people this amount of attack could
actually you know send somebody into a
dark place that I won't even mention out
loud and it's not worth television I I
can agree with you more I mean you're
not wrong you're not wrong that while
Tom and and Rachel made a mistake you
know they don't deserve to be bullied to
the point where people are telling them
to kill themselves and and and things
like that it's it's terrible stuff and
we unfortunately we live in this kind of
mob mentality world where unfortunately
F some fans
not I would say a small majority small
minority of fans uh don't see us as
human beings they see us as actual
characters and they're there's this
weird thing of like I know you who you
are because you're playing yourself but
they don't they don't treat us like
human beings they they treat us like
characters they would hate on on a
Marvel movie and things like that and
they don't think the things that they're
saying to us and the comments and the
DMS and one of the most common
occurrences for a reality TV I guess it
maybe any celebrity but I've experienced
as someone on reality TV and I'm someone
who received a lot of criticism at times
when my time on the show and I've I've
received some pretty nasty and hateful
comments and and I I I try I almost
never respond to to people but if I ever
were to respond it's always with
kindness It's always like oh like I'm
sorry for you know sorry for upsetting
you or whatever and a 100 times out of a
100 the response is like oh my God I
didn't think you would see that I love
you and this is after they would say
something it's called trolling that's
what they're doing trolling want
attention you know and it's just they
just want to be validated and and and
things like that so I just kind of
learned not to take it personally and
it's I find it shocking I find it
shocking that in one second someone
could tell me to you know I should just
die and I should just kill myself you
know and and then the next comment tell
me that they love me and they're just
kidding you know but I don't know why
everybody are great joke writers not
everybody know how to write a joke you
know what I do like though you've made
it very clear multiple times on your
podcast that you will not say someone is
a narcissist or something like that
because I think people do throw around
like you were saying therapy terms a
little bit too much and like when they
see a villain or see anyone that they
deem as a villain on um um a reality
show like now it's Tom they say he's a
narcissist but no one is a therapist in
order to that's like an actual diagnosis
just like everyone comes up to you and
says oh I have a little OCD too it's
like the same thing it's not for people
to diagnose the people that they see on
television I just think people are lazy
and I think instead of having Nuance
conversations and trying to understand
what these words mean they just try to
insert them into their vocabulary
because it's just easier to be like oh g
g PL means that like someone like you
know is trying to make me feel crazy
well what H when you're in an argument
with someone have you ever not felt
crazy like when you're arguing with your
wife have you ever argued with your wife
I have never had an argument of
disagreement in my lifeone I never feel
crazy I'm always right every once in a
while now and I will argue and we almost
never argue and I'll tell you what when
we're arguing we both are like what are
you thinking you know but like that
doesn't mean you're gaslighting anyways
yeah I think it's irresponsible to
diagnose anyone with these terms gasing
is not even the actual DSM like
therapists won't even diagnosis and I
also think there's real there's there's
real narcissists There's real sociopaths
There's real abusers there's bad people
out there and I think we're doing
ourselves a disservice by using this
language and watering down the meaning
of these terms and there's nothing like
a um a podcaster and reality star and
talent judge and uh school teacher to
teach the people what these terms are
and to really talk about these terms the
point is that I don't think people
understand the um the reality of TV and
their own lives they take this very
seriously they take it really to heart
and they legitimately as I saw and was a
party to uh get like it ruins or makes
their life other people's um faas and
and trouble and anger like why are you
get I don't get I've never gotten that
angry at somebody I know let alone a
stranger that you just watched and
listened to well I think the Tom thing
got you know why people got so upset is
cuz I think they're you know whether
it's actually two-thirds of people on
tindering relationships I think cheating
and infidelity is so
common uh and most people who are
victims of infidelity feel like they
Justice wasn't served for them that
they're the person who victimized them
and cheated on them kind of got away
with it wasn't really held accountable
and I think for all those people
and specifically women because majority
of people majority of women watch the
Vander pump not all you know I'm a huge
fan but um it Tom was Tom kind of was
the person they could hold accountable
you know they couldn't hold their person
accountable so they could hold Tom
accountable and they kind of projected
their their situation onto Tom I think
that's why people it that's why it hit
main stream but also like reality TV
very much for the people who are reality
TV fans uh they consume it just sports
fans it's their Sports you know and
that's why they get as passionate as
they do because not only do they like
rooting for their team they love hating
other I I I love hating the Minnesota
Vikings as much as I enjoy rooting for
the Green Bay
Packers